فبعد غيابه لاكثر من 20 عاما عن بطوله
دوري ابطال اوروبا عدا نادي نيوكاسل
الانجليزي الى البطوله الاوروبيه الاعرق
في التاريخ نيوكاسل حققه تعادل في اخر
مباراه هذا الموسم امام ليستر سيتي بهذه
النتيجه يضمن التاهل التاهل المباشر الى
البطوله الاوروبيه وبدات احتفالات
اللاعبين ايضا والجماهير المشاهدين عقب
نهايه مباراه الفريق في استاد جيمس بارك
اما النتائج تحسنت عقب استحواذ صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه السعودي عليه منتصف
الموسم الماضي واداره لفتره تعاقدات ناجحه
في الصيف الماضي ادت الى وصوله لهذا
المستوى بالتاكيد هذا الاستثمار الجيد
الذي ليستر سيتي انتقل من الدرجه الثانيه
الى الدرجه الاولى فمالك النادي حقق مع
بعد
طبعا بطوله الدوري الانجليزي ارتفعت اسهم
هذا النادي الى اليوم هذا التاهل ايضا
سيرفع اسهم هذا النادي بشكل اعتقد بالدوري
الانجليزي كمان هاد بهاي الدوره في نادي
ارسنال كمان برضو كان من بالدوره الماضيه
كان من المتاخرين جدا ومن المرجح يطلع
وارتفع النادي وارتفع كثير معه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات